today we're going to talk about low
potassium okay the signs the symptoms
the causes the treatment all the details
about potassium I've done a lot of
videos on potassium I'm always updating
my videos I'm finding new information
I'm also reminding people about things
that are really really important and out
of all the minerals I think potassium is
at the top of the list as far as
importance so the reason why we need
potassium mainly is because it's a part
of a certain enzyme or a pump in all of
your cells called the sodium and
potassium pump okay that is a pump that
keeps these two minerals separated to a
certain degree to create a battery
effect in your cells so potassium is
intimately involved in the power in the
cells and I'm talking about the power to
generate energy for your nervous system
primarily as well as your muscular
system okay all your muscles and I'm not
just talking about your skeletal muscles
from your legs and your arms but the
muscles in your colon the muscles and
the lung which is the diaphragm which is
a little bit different but that's not a
skeletal muscle but it allows you to
breathe so that's a really really
important function right there it also
is involved in PH and potassium also
works with other minerals like sodium
for example it can also work with
magnesium and so in the diet for example
if one is going too high the other one
will also need to go up as well for
example you don't have to worry about
consuming too much sodium as long as
your potassium is at least twice as high
and so the average person needs like 4
700 milligrams of potassium and like
half of that sodium ideally but that can
increase if you're going up with sodium
but the average person is not consuming
even close to what they really need of
potassium and this is why this video is
important because most people are
deficient in potassium so you should
know the symptoms you should know how
you become deficient it's not always
from your diet but the medical term for
low potassium is hypocalemia
okay that means low potassium in your
blood the thing you need to know with
potassium is that 98 of all the
potassium is located inside the cell
only two percent is outside the cell in
your blood so when you get a blood test
you're really only measuring a very tiny
bit like two percent of all your
potassium in your body so it's not the
best way to know what's going on deeper
inside the body an intracellular
potassium test is more difficult and
sometimes it's hard to find a lab that
will do that so let's kind of go through
the symptoms of low potassium okay
number one would be muscle weakness okay
let's say you're climbing up the stairs
and you're like oh my gosh my legs are
just so heavy or you're starting
exercise and you just don't have the gas
you just feel kind of tuckered out that
could be a potassium deficiency this is
why it might be good sometimes to take
an electrolyte powder with potassium to
get more energy while you're exercising
a lot of times people will feel a
significant difference with that now we
also have your lungs which is controlled
by the diaphragm so in other words a
lack of potassium can affect your
breathing right it's harder to breathe
a lack of potassium can affect the colon
muscles the peristalsis the pumping
action of your digestive system and that
can show up as constipation as a symptom
and also you can notice cramping in your
calves in your feet in other parts of
your body you can even notice twitching
but also twitching could be a lack of
calcium as well or even magnesium a lot
of these minerals kind of cross over so
cramps in your calf could be potassium
it could be magnesium it could be
calcium so this is why the video to kind
of learn a little bit more about the
overview of this one mineral another
common symptom is arrhythmias the heart
rhythm another one would be hypertension
as in high blood pressure and even as
that might relate to vascular
stiffness in other words potassium helps
keep the arteries soft okay to prevent
high blood pressure so 90 of all
hypertension is called essential which
means unknown cause I think a good
portion of that is either a potassium
deficiency
insulin resistance or
a low vitamin D situation another
symptom would be fatigue and then
another one alkalosis you have a
situation where potassium is intimately
involved with helping regulate your pH
so if your blood is a little bit too
alkaline or too acid potassium is
usually involved if the pH is more
alkaline in your blood okay potassium is
going to move from your blood more into
the cell so you'll end up with less
potassium potassium is also involved in
the storage of sugar in your liver and
in your muscles it's called glycogen so
if you're consuming sugar
you'll lose potassium
in this in the sugar itself it kind of
gets stuck in the liver and the muscles
it becomes unavailable to you unless you
use up that sugar so um but that's just
one way that you could become deficient
in potassium another symptom would be
insomnia
um another symptom would be a higher
pulse rate so potassium keeps your pulse
rate lower and another condition called
pulsatile tinnitus now what is that that
is a situation where you start hearing
your pulse beat okay it could be a
swishing or a pounding where you put
your head in the pillow and you just
hear your heart beat just pounding like
that it's not even necessarily a higher
pulse rate you just hear or feel your
heart rate okay that is a potassium
deficiency all right so now the question
is
how do you become deficient in the first
place it could be because you're not
consuming foods high in potassium that's
a common cause and then also you're
eating a lot of junk foods which are
loaded with sodium that really throws
off your ratios another few common
causes would be you're losing fluids
like your vomit uh you're doing
excessive laxatives where you're you're
losing fluids or you have diarrhea that
could be the reason why you're deficient
in potassium another common thing is
diuretics diuretics many times will pull
out sodium and potassium stress in
general can create a potassium
deficiency and this is why a condition
where you have high levels of cortisol
called Cushing syndrome can give you
signs of a potassium deficiency so by
taking potassium you can feel calmer you
can have more energy you can have more
strength in your muscles you can have
better bowel movements but like I
mentioned before
potassium is involved with storing sugar
so one way to to deplete or shift
the available potassium to the
unavailable potassium is to eat a lot of
sugar or refined carbs okay
I have done that many times in my 20s
in my 30s now and I'm being very
sarcastic I'm in my 50s and I haven't
consumed refined sugars in many many
years but when I used to eat a lot of
sugar I had a lot of these symptoms that
we're talking about this is why
diabetics are usually always deficient
in potassium and they should be
consuming a good amount of potassium the
higher their blood sugars are and so
even potassium can help the insulin work
better it can help the insulin
resistance situation now when someone
starts the ketogenic diet they lose a
lot of glycogen since a lot of that
potassium is stuck in that glycogen
they're going to also lose a lot of
potassium this is why when you're on the
ketogenic plant I always recommend take
electrolytes to get back that potassium
so you want to get heavy potassium
definitely a good amount of sodium as
well to get your electrolytes back
drinking a tremendous amount of water
forcing yourself to drink like a gallon
of water can definitely do it as well
when you're doing fasting okay I always
recommend adding more potassium as well
as sodium as in sea salts through the
process that way you can keep your
electrolytes up because you're not
eating any food and so you need to be
taking these nutrients because you don't
really store a lot of these electrolytes
for a long period of time so if you're
doing prolonged fasting you could really
end up with a potassium deficiency and
feel faint and even pass out you know
that's not a good thing so take your
electrolytes if you're fasting if you
have low magnesium that can affect your
potassium as well okay because they it
takes a certain amount of magnesium to
retain potassium and the last thing that
can affect potassium is if you get
injured or you go through surgery yeah
and so that can shock the body it's a
big source of stress and then you could
just dump your potassium and end up with
hypokalemia so what are the best foods
to get your potassium what about a
banana well a banana has a lot of sugar
and it only has like 300 milligrams for
a medium-sized banana you need 4 700
milligrams okay so a banana is not a
good source of potassium what about
potatoes well potato has a good amount
of potassium but it also has all that
starch unless you consume a raw potato
which you're probably not going to do I
would avoid potatoes too so these are
the foods that are high in potassium at
the top of the list you have beet leaves
if you put those in your salad you'll
have a lot of potassium you also have
any type of leafy green is loaded with
potassium the salads I need the
cruciferous vegetables any of the leafy
greens will give you enough potassium
avocados are a very good source of
potassium squash and lima beans have a
good amount of potassium now of course
lima beans are in the bean family I
don't really recommend consuming a lot
of those if you're going to have them
have a small amount and we also have
salmon has a good amount of potassium so
potassium is not just in vegetables it's
also in certain Meats as well so I hope
you now have a better understanding of
ask him and a better appreciation of
potassium if you haven't seen this video
on electrolytes that I did I have a very
cool demo in this video to show you how
potassium and other electrolytes can
power your body check it out I put it up
right here